Elena is with us in Boston hi Elena how
are you I am so good Dave how are you
better than I deserved I mispronounced
your name
no you pronounce it correctly thank you
so much sure good I just want to make
sure how can I help well first thank you
so much for everything you do I'm in
such a better place as since I've been
following your program and I'm just so
thankful for you for changing my life so
thank you so much I had a question about
a work travel I've been at my company
for six and a half years but I just got
promoted within the same company to be a
corporate trainer but that job requires
me to pay for my own travel and then get
reimbursed so I did here yeah I did here
you know one of your podcast previously
as somebody else had a similar question
so I got myself a prepaid debit card and
I was planning on keeping around you
know maybe 2,000 or so in there so that
my travel is going to be a little bit
more than I expected I think and I have
to put more in there and I'm just really
nervous about having made me more like
five or six thousand tied up you know
kind of always in being revolving for
this travel so I kind of just wanted to
talk to you get your thoughts um I mean
well it's the nervous part is is that
your company wants you to do that I mean
you know about if you use a credit card
you have that much tied up to okay if it
makes you nervous a debit card it ought
to make you EE nervous if you use the
credit card so I mean I don't mind what
I always suggest to road warriors and it
sounds like you're going to be doing a
lot of road work is to probably not do
the prepaid just because it's kind of a
hassle instead I would just open a
separate checking account that's just
travel and just have that debit card is
my travel card I don't use that debit
card for anything anything ever except
reimbursable expenses right and if
you're going to have something on while
you're on the road that's personal just
use your other use your other debit card
your personal card but use your travel
account for travel reimbursable things
only but I mean these guys are asking
you to float them five thousand dollars
at a time
well I may be overestimating how much
I'll really be spending but every time
I've been down for at least just one
overnight it's about $1,000 and the
reimbursement to vote you know maybe one
to two weeks and I'll be calm I just I
think I might just not be an obstinate
or anything but I probably swing back
into leadership team and go guys you're
asking me to carry an awful lot of money
here you probably ought to just give me
a gray card because I mean it's
different if you're just out like once
every six months or something
reimbursable on that's reasonable but
they're asking you to stay on the road
and basically asking you to use $5,000
of your money at any given time so that
they don't have that much in float and
that's that's really not okay I mean
that's that's asking a lot no I
completely agree I I know this is the
policy it's been that way so I do try to
plan on being the person that changes
that policies um you know I just don't
know if they really know how I just
think you Sedalia remember your leader
is and just have a reasonable I'm not
trying to be obviously I'm trying to
lose my job over this but let's just
have a reasonable conversation like you
know this is swap shoes here for a
second once you walk around in my shoes
and you know you're you're you guys are
asking me to use five thousand dollars
of my money this big company needs me to
be their bank it's you know probably
time on somebody that's had that heavy a
travel to relook your policy or at least
in my case I'm just asking you to
consider it even if you don't do it
company-wide
and I'm right you know and maybe you get
up negative answer and then you just
have to deal with it and but maybe you
you're the first one that breaks the
cycle because this is kind of over the
top really I mean that's a lot it's a
lot to ask somebody to do that hey
thanks for the call hey you guys Rachael
Cruz here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right kind of bad
save room to channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you